j'aimerais commencer par vous présenter
quatre personnes deux hommes et deux
femmes
florian un jeune homme de 20 ans qui n'a
pas eu son bac mais qui adore bricoler
avec son ordinateur et qui adore les
jeux vidéo à côté de lui manuel une
jeune femme de 44 ans qui a trois
enfants qui a tenu une boulangerie
pendant 12 ans et après il a eu un
accident cérébral graf et ne peut plus
aujourd'hui exercer son ancien métier
vous avez à côté high squatte une jeune
femme qui vient du pays basque
elle était il ya encore un an une
institutrice dans une école maternelle
il s'occupait des tout petits enfin
balthazar un jeune homme qui porte un
short l'hiver comme l'été
il a fait des études de cinéma et qui
s'est dit en fait tu voulais pas faire
du cinéma il s'est retrouvé au chômage
ces quatre personnes si différente
compte il un commun ils sont tous
aujourd'hui devenus des développeurs
savez le métier de développeur c'est
celui qui crée des sites internet des
applications web mobiles
ce métier en fait aujourd'hui il est
devenu tout à fait accessible il s'est
démocratisé considérablement
on est loin de l'image du geek
boutonneux devant son écran
non le métier il est il s'est ouvert
c'est d'ailleurs un véritable
accélérateur de carrière quel autre
domaine vous permet de changer votre vie
professionnelle aussi radicalement dans
ce domaine il ya des nouveaux métiers
qui apparaissent tous les jours d'autres
meurent par exemple le métier de 2,8
masters il a été remplacé il n'ya pas
longtemps par le métier de community
manager vous ne le savez peut-être pas
mais en europe 1 2020 il va nous falloir
900 mille professionnels sachant qu des
90% des métiers exigeront des
compétences numériques dans ces
conditions va travailler dans le
numérique
là c'est passionnant il ya le métier de
développeur
il ya d'autres métiers en pénurie comme
designer community manager datasite east
travailler dans le numérique c'est
passionnant mais peut s'apparenter
parfois de courir un marathon
parce qu'il faut cours est de plus en
plus vite rester à jour il ya
aujourd'hui des développeurs au chômage
comme il ya aussi une pénurie de
développeurs et les développeurs au
chômage ce sont ceux qui n'ont pas couru
assez vite qui ont décroché alors dans
cet univers où tout va de plus en plus
vite
suite aux nouvelles technologies qui
veulent ou est-ce que cela fait encore
du sens de faire des études longues
certes il encore à quelque chose de
faire un master un bac plus cinq pains
saisi ce que vous allez apprendre en
première année ça va devenir obsolète
un cinquième est ce que vous allez faire
3 1 après la fin de vos études va
probablement y en aura probablement plus
rien à voir avec ce que vous avez étudié
non cela n'a plus de sens de rester
pendant des années éloigné de la vraie
vie professionnelle alors pourquoi un
tentons aujourd'hui certains dire que
les études se prolonge qu'il ya des
étudiants qui veulent de faire des
études de plus en plus long qu'on se
contente de moins en moins d'un bac + 2
bac + 3 on veut faire un master et puis
il y en a qui veulent faire un docteur
ras il ya une véritable inflation des
diplômes vous allez me dire qu'en fait
c'est des métiers qui dément de plus en
plus de compétences
ah non c'est les formations désolé
qu'ils sont de moins en moins adapté et
après une formation de trois ans
inadapté bel étudiant il se sent pas
prêt pour affronter le vrai monde
professionnel donc il va faire encore
des années d'études et après master 1
bacs le 5 mai ils se sentent toujours
pas prêt pas plus qu après un bac +3 et
demandé un thésard chisso sens s'il se
sent prêt non on n'est jamais prêt
figurez-vous un ami à moi a dû supprimer
de son cv la mention de son doctorat
pour enfin être embauchés en fait notre
système scolaire nos pouces verts
toujours de plus en plus d'études vers
la carrière universitaire dans un sens
or à l'université il n'y a pas de
débouchés
alors comment apprendre autrement
comment changer le système
comment le rendre plus efficace plus
agile plus proche des besoins des
métiers commun enfin évitez soukous
extraordinaire pour la société des
années d'études pour apprendre des
métiers sans débouchés j'ai envie de
partager avec vous trois idées première
idée faut arrêter de penser études
longues faut penser cours modulaire je
fais une formation de cinq mois et puis
je vais travailler et puis plus tard je
vais encore une autre sphère une autre
formation de cinq mois et puis je vais
travailler
deuxième idée il faut arrêter de
cloisonner l'enseignement il faut
arrêter de distinguer formation initiale
formation continue
pincez
pensons ensemble pierre un jeune homme
vient d'avoir son bac il va s'inscrire à
l'université
il va peut-être au allé dans une école
d'ingénieurs il va faire cinq ans
d'études pour ensuite travailler comme
développeur logiciel ip prénom marque
un jeune homme de 30 ans technicien du
secteur automobile qui va faire une
formation d'un an et ensuite il va
travailler comme développeur logiciel
est ce justifié
que l'on va faire des études de cinq ans
pour apprendre le métier que l'autre va
apprendre un une année ma troisième idée
lui numérique
il nous permet d'automatiser
l'enseignement une partie de
l'enseignement imaginons vous êtes en
train d'écouter en cours sur comment
parler en public
votre enseignant va vous parler de bonne
pratique va vous partagez ces techniques
est en fait cette insignia et va répéter
les mêmes techniques plusieurs fois
devant plusieurs salles autant de fois
qu'il va donner son cours alors avec
l'outil numérique
l'enseignant va pouvoir enregistrer son
cours en vidéo va écrire dans un
document en ligne
la consigne est ensuite et va rendre
disponibles ses ressources à tous ses
étudiants
avant même le début du cours ainsi les
étudiants quand il arrive un cours elles
sont préparés peuvent poser des
questions et l'enseignant peut aller
plus vite donc l'outil informatique
permet de gagner du temps et avec ce
temps l'enseignant est faux il peut se
consacrer davantage à l'accompagnement
individuel de chacun de ses élèves à
partir de ces idées moi j'ai créé
l'output school une école en forme des
personnes issues d'horizons divers au
métier de développeur web
en cinq mois dans cette école nous ne
faisons pas de distinction entre la
formation
les formations continues on utilise
aussi l'outil numérique pour automatiser
une partie de l'apprentissage
et pour faire gagner du temps aux
formateurs pour qu'ils puissent
davantage se consacré à l'accompagnement
individuel de ses élèves à ce propos
j'aimerais vous raconter une histoire ya
dix ans j'étais jeune enseignante à
l'université je vais 25 ans génie mais
en cours avec un professeur expérimenté
j'avais envie de d'emilio raymond
enseignement d'aller au delà des exposés
classique donc j'imagine et des
exercices ludiques des ateliers
interactifs des gens sérieux
j'ai proposé cette nouvelle méthode à
mon professeur
malheureusement n'a pas du tout apprécié
les m'a dit anna cela ne fait pas partie
de notre tradition universitaire cela ne
va pas marcher mais de toute façon les
étudiants vont faire la grève qu'est ce
que j'avais à faire soit j'essaie je
poursuis avec mes idées et je risque la
sanction je ne pourrai plus compter sur
le soutien du professeur ou alors pas
j'abandonne je fais comme tout le monde
je m'inscris dans la tradition
universitaire je me suis déjà trop envie
ch'ti dans la préparation de mes
exercices interactifs pour laisser
tomber comme ça donc j'ai décidé de
poursuivre donc je fais je fais ma
méthode mes exercices le profit sont là
même pas remarqué d'ailleurs
et finalement les étudiants ont apprécié
ils ont réussi leurs examens et personne
n'a fait de grève
alors cette histoire m'a fait comprendre
une chose que si on croit en quelque
chose véritablement quelles que soient
les difficultés
mais alors il faut essayer faut
expérimenter faut oser ça va peut-être
échoué mais ça peut aussi réussir
et là vous aurez gagné
donc moi j'ai osé créer la white kotze
cool et c'est parce que j'ai osé que
emmanuel ice quoi florian balthazar et
des dizaines d'autres ont aujourd'hui un
métier où il s'éclate
merci à vous